mentre ragazzi sto scaricando il nuovo
aggiornamento di flight simulator x
vedere che cacchio tirano fuori ma che
voglio assolutamente provare la nuova
moto che esistono nei giochi particolari
ad esempio questo chiamato youtuber
tournament e punto exe proviamolo
ragazzi verso gli totali treccia il 3
top eight x1 e la juve time quando cio
tempo faccio l'update questo ci ha detto
allora abbiamo ovviamente un miliardo di
youtuber che si contenderanno il primo
posto
noi sappiamo già chi vincerà perché
lollis lectra ovviamente è superiore
però solo devi fare lo fanno neanche
scelto lui sapeva che sarei voluto
essere nullo sapeva contro mike mike
official passo slap col passo ma io cosa
faccio lo faccio niente ma come se la
cava in un sola chi giocando sala
sbagliano in faccia davies la pagherò
appaiono in faccia bravo devi ma in un
ottimo farci comandi ma cosa significa
io non sto comandando niente io so solo
assist e telecronista sono guido meda
bravo devi veramente impressionante
questo combattimento io sono del
pubblico
bravo devi fare perfetto logan paul
versus think i'm l'unica cosa che posso
fare è scusato e questo bene oddio non
ho mai sentito che si chiamava lui un
ricordo per bene però va beh chi se ne
frega piping ai ko madonna che porta lo
capone a terra attenzione è uno scontro
veramente all'ultimo sangue voglio
vedere lo camporosso schiena i solo
fanno domanda domande ma il gioco è
precisato si sa che deve andare così
oppure randomica la faccenda si vede
come si muovono i tizi madonna che botta
nel pallino del bravo ping rai
attenzione non ci credo da terra hanno
campo riesce a sferrare il colpo della
vittoria e si passa al prossimo match
mister viste parte che ha una mazza
chiodata quindi secondo me è un po vaga
per attenzione le prende i servizi delle
prede non si sa come va beh mi servisse
le prende veramente tantissimo mi
servisse una meritata epica che botta
nel padre veramente violenti non vorrei
dargli meno male che non hanno messo in
mezzo
vince dani ragazzi anche se in oro chi
sia però una tastiera sulla schiena cosa
che potrebbe succedere anche a me se
continua a giocare abbiamo linus contro
video che in tanti titoli da chi ragazzi
non so se lo conoscete un canale
pazzesco io tifo per danti ovviamente
speriamo forchia trottola 16 che per
tanti si accettano scommesse questo tipo
ma che botte e tipo l'arena di
gladiatori cesare youtuber tour.it e
saluta bravo danti che se la cava anche
sul finale compito di questo ragazzino
scontro pazzesco vediamo quello che
uscirà fuori mark player contro più di
pai questo poi è veramente un
benissimo scontro vediamo chi la spunta
la supremazia ragazzi non è scontata è
allora che botta 62 ripetono sera in
vantaggio attenzione da terra si gira e
colpisce ma il play anche per il
recupero madonna ragazzi che incontro
pazzesco ma all ultimo sangue sul serio
gli fai ancora viene sconfitto
brutalmente con un'avanzata totale di
marc meilleur complimenti mar
mi dispiace un po per i capelli che ti
hanno fatto ma va beh signori la prima
manche è finita però incontri si
intensificano perché adesso abbiamo devi
file o fuori contro logan pol
vediamo cosa esce fuori perché sulla
carta che gli fai un fuori è molto più
debole ma l'estremo potere del passato
che un poi prendo un po di mazzate
all'inizio perfetto anche dei mii però
sono pari sono pari si scontra
attenzione dei vip la mazzata finale
fila fuori dall islam there is no
maledizione persone preferiti ne
valevano facies con me provoca un polo
può essere così opino vale coi guantoni
panda anche prima che arrivi in finale
gesù perché conosco quindi il primo zero
per chi ha una tastiera sulla schiena
questo momento vi prego di scoprire
questa cosa spiegatemelo mazzate perda
anche per non potrebbe riprendersi
proprio adesso che ha vinto noi soli
nati entrambi lega si sono eliminati
entrambi ma cosa che ha vinto sono morti
tutti e due no si deve rifare non ci
voglio credere
se ne riparla che sono eliminati
entrambi lo 20 madonna che slap ha vinto
da anche stavolta
pazzesco lei mi se n'è andato quindi poi
sono andato quindi due topi son finiti
madonna che porta la macchina stai calmo
però davvero tra gli spalti dei
patemi che da lontano un processo
lineare
sono potuti venivano parte stai calmo
perché sta inceppando tutto questo
castello
ti prego abbi pietà per la gente stavo
scherzando di impegnarti molto di più
marche molto male allora jack safety che
contro critical ragazzi che non ho io
voglio capire chi siano messi voglio
vedere chiavari questo tizio perché non
può avere un mondo in mano non è normale
tra capo caccia in testa un ragazzo è
veramente lo so l'arma è un'arma la
diffusione e l'arma del secolo cos'è sta
roba
guarda è l'imbattibile questo dice
vincerà lui è impossibile è troppo forte
non lo puoi di spodestare michael a fare
la logan poi contro vedendo anche
lesioni a un po che prego dantis podesta
l'ok a un polpo che non può vincere
sempre cenno nemmeno una questa cosa
perfavore tanti vinci 2 bravo bravo da
anche i ko simeone campo non lo ferisce
neanche per sbaglio è quello che ho
fatto non ho proprio ok per attenzione
no lo campo è troppo forte rai non ha
senso squadra martello contro lido raga
questo lo scontro tra titani
ma veramente teloni in faccia ma tuttora
attenzione si prende qualche tiro fa
male tutto carica eccoli mega incazzato
maio sinica lista partito posizione per
ogni dove prendono
titanico eccolo martellato finale yes
gran finale ragazzi pyro silica o si
qualifica mi dispiace perché tutti i
migliori tutti i miei preferiti sono
stati eliminati dunk hi jack settiche
mar player dei viepiù ripari sono andati
all'altro mondo ma la finale la vediamo
logan po il verso sparse nicola sgro
raga fate un incontro pulito per favore
ecco penso sia molto più avantaggiato
col martello stroke e logan per colpire
deve stare un pò chi métro invece
l'altro popolo dirà distanza logan non
sta neanche toccando porto ne voglio che
mamma guardalo vittoria devastante se
non che ha vinto la proprio tease in
tela small e colato pezzo perverso
complimenti zio rotto canale perché non
lo conosco ma next match e ora succede
così si chiama premiazione odiavo
premiazione
scollo un mucchio di yeah a caso schermo
nero va bene complimenti appaio sinica
hai guadagnato la mia iscrizione che
sono investiti temi mentre installava è
stato un bel gioco comunque complimenti
voglio uscire la sta roba e cancellarlo
dal mio computer ha mai più ragazzi
[Musica]